for the reds vladimir gutierrez his
numbers from western and southern his
second outing against the padres
over the course of the last two weeks
i think it's always interesting to see
especially with the rookie the second
time around you face a team
they've obviously seen you now
what adjustments will you make what
adjustments will they make
out front swinging to miss strike three
breaking ball from gutierrez dispatches
up tatis bitching for the padres tonight
is no no joe joe muskrobe yeah the 28
year old right-hander making his 15th
start we always say this is a big start
for joe musgrove because he has to
handle a huge load and what i mean about
that
heavy workload last night from the
bullpen joe understands that's a huge
responsibility for him and he embraces
that winker is one for 12 against
musgrove in his career
miss that one back in second cronin
worth out there's his second hit little
blooper india turns and holds grisham
swooping in lobs it in
and statsman joel luckup did it again
nick castillanos with two aboard nobody
out
castillanos
drills it to right field
and out of here
home run nick castigamos
the mvp campaign
continues home run number 16
his team leading 51st 52nd 53rd
rbis
lock
just smile that's it just
that's my commentary just a smile
amazing five of the first six reds
hitters have reached now kyle farmer
farmer
that should be more than deep enough
right center grisham the catch motto
tags throw to second bottle scores sac
fly rbi kyle farmer russia meyers and
profar featured here in the second
inning against gutierrez you had a long
wait
it's a high fly ball to right field back
goes castiano's at the wall that ball is
gone
home run for trenth grisham his ninth of
the year and the padres with a quick
answer here in the second inning home
run for trent grisham first run of the
night for the padres comes on a big fly
well donna that's one way to do it will
myers batting here with a 250 average
this season myers batting out of the
sixth spot of the order and he hits one
a ton to deep left field and that ball
is very gone up into the top tank
will myers leaves with his ninth of the
year and the padres have their second
run as they go back to back a blast that
was to left field for myers quick answer
here by the padres in the second inning
now so good for will myers to get off to
a good start tonight one out base is
empty top of the order jonathan india
will stand in for the second time
swinging a mess in a pitch in the dirt
and striking out is india that's the
first strikeout of the night for joe
musgrove third walk of the night issued
by musk this one coming with two outs in
the second inning and that puts a man
aboard for castellanos
and he went around according to home
plate umpire nick marley they ring up
castellanos two strikeouts from muskrobe
4-2 red fernando tatis jr coming up
highest ops in the month of june
fernando third in that category his 30th
pitch is hit in the air down the
left-field line and that ball will be
gone home run right down the line and
towards the pole it goes and fernando
hits his 26th home run of the year in
the padres back within a run i wasn't
sure that was going to stay fair it did
it's a one-run game now
i love the fight in the padres and this
offense continues to show it toddy 5 48
average on the first pitch myers homer
his first time up
grounded left side
farmer
it began with a tatties home run the
reds still enjoy the lead joey votto
leads off against joe musgrove
vato
annihilates it to right field 1 000 rbis
so here's your short list
johnny bench tony perez pete rose frank
robinson
and now the fifth and only other end
with 1 000 rbis in that uniform joseph
daniel
the crowd is still standing they know
the significance of that shot here it
comes at a
dab this is filled with friars with one
out and trent grisham about to face a
new pitcher on to face him is josh osage
and a fly ball headed to right field
that ball is back and the slam diego
padres are on the road in cincinnati and
they take a 7-5 lead with one swing of
the bat trent grisham with his second
home run of the night and this one is a
grand slam
trent grisham is on fire what a perfect
approach second hit of the night for
castillanos and that takes us to joey
votto
ground ball right side chronoworth flips
to second for one on to first they got a
chance and they got him double play joey
bono does not run terribly well and a
4-6-3 dp will end the fifth inning
grounds crew is just out talking to the
umpires hard downpour of rain
giant bolts of lightning loud claps of
thunder most fans hover underneath the
overhang cno perez his first appearance
since his latest call up from triple a
breaking ball swinger to miss strike
three
look at this
it's still not quite as bad as what
lucas sims had to throw in but here
comes the grounds crew
they've called for the tarp
you know there's something to being out
in the rain i like a good rainy day once
in a while don't like it during the ball
game no that is fully on brand
welcome back out to great american
ballpark where tonight this game has
been officially called it is a final and
the padres have beaten the reds seven to
five tonight
this game rolls back to the fifth inning
because the padres scored in the fifth
and the reds had a chance to answer in
the bottom of the fifth inning that
makes this an official game